okay so this one is Riley Sonny we're
like ah some of the stuff maybe Riley is
just like out of his realm and it's very
obvious the time to get reaches now you
need to stop waiting and start making
money like I don't get what you're
saying okay tell me who only needs tell
me where to start right
yeah yeah yeah I mean that's like such a
common trophy yeah you got it mate when
is there not a time to be making sure
the kid ever actually give any tips on
how to make money or is it just well not
in the tick tocks but in his program he
does okay but he he's generated a lot of
money this kid's making bank right now
too so he doesn't know what he's talking
about like how old are you the only time
to make money is now what are you 16 17
of the week yeah yeah you need to start
making money yeah you're [__] up like
I don't get white he's honestly not
wrong though like you know it is only
gonna get harder and harder to make
money as time goes on and like more
people come on to the internet money
wave and the inflation keeps kicking in
like it's just it's only going to get
harder so the best time to start is now
even if you are 16 and in school the
best time to start anything is now
always you're still listening to a
teacher who only makes forty thousand
dollars a year and is trying to tell you
how to get rich teachers don't make that
much 40K depending on where you are I
feel like that's a stretch uh that's
kind of his point it's like you go and
you learn from these people about how to
be successful but they're working a job
that doesn't pay anything so it's like
that's kind of his point if you're
trying to make money learn from people
who aren't making money but yeah it's
you know it is it kind of isn't but I
also but also your teachers aren't
teaching you how to get rich that's not
their job no so he's like why are you
listening to a teacher on how to get
rich we're not no one is they don't even
teach you about financials in high
school yeah college but his his way of
saying he's like don't [__] listen to
anything they gotta say your science
teacher has spent their entire life
learning science as a bachelor inside
[__] wrong [__] tell them to shut the
[__] up now [__]
let me ask you a question real quick
okay have you ever seen your teacher
drive a Lambo [__] no they're all broken
that line has to be like he's leaning
into it so much right have you ever seen
your teacher they're all broken I feel
like I'm starting to sound like that is
that is jokes that is too funny
Riley we're gonna go look first of all I
have one thing to say about the first
video that I've been shown by you you're
a [__] idiot dude okay so we're gonna
move on all right oh dude dude I think
I've seen this yeah in your 20s and you
don't have a Lamborghini you should
actually sit down and have like a
serious discussion with yourself as to
why you don't have a Lambo because it's
I realize now that it's so incredibly
easy and right wabashed and wardrobe
that guy's a w that's like I I I don't
even disagree like you don't need a
Lambo to be validated but if you can't
afford a Lambo by that like in your 20s
like I agree like you gotta like step it
up like you only need a couple years of
focus to make a lot of money you don't
need all this time like the Matrix tells
you where you gotta put a hundred
dollars in an account for 60 years and
then it's worth one point to no that's
[__] that doesn't even work anymore
all these old people telling us what to
do with our money is nonsense all right
well if these people are teaching people
how to make all this kind of money
you're one of them you know then then so
be it then then there are no excuses for
not making good money but it does sound
really cocky and flip to be like hey if
you're 23 and you don't have a Lambo you
know you're you're a loser it's not nice
it's not helpful yeah but you can look
at that and you can get butt hurt or you
can say okay maybe I gotta step up my
game yeah well hopefully it's the latter
yeah they kind of half believe what
they're saying but they're playing into
the culture that it's like say just the
most ridiculous [__] about being rich
yeah to to get a lot of attention on you
I wish I had
I want guns in our videos now I'm gonna
make the rest of this video especially
hard for Alex there's a there's a gun in
my hand right now Alex at this time
and I looked at him and I said why do
you need my money and then yeah me it's
not derogatory man some broken isn't
your whole story supposed to be how you
can become rich from nothing like why
are you but that's their whole thing is
they're yelling at the starting point
that's how they do it that's like Andrew
Tate's whole thing it's like bullying
people telling them they're [__]
losers yeah they get better be upset
about everything in your life right now
by the way the pressure can be here in
two weeks yeah just so you know I looked
at him and I said why do you need my
money and then he said
he said jacket dude
these guys do need to understand that
some people respond really well to that
like that tough love he'll call it
bullying like you're you're a loser get
up go do something that works really
well for some people not everybody wants
to be cuddled so there was an audience
for it guess they're not the audience I
looked at him and I said go make money
then the guy said back to me that his
job doesn't pay enough and what I say to
that is get out of the Rat Race
great advice
what is the rat race dude what's the
real advice oh investing yeah get out of
the road Grace Just invest your money
that you don't have if you will he said
get into e-commerce that's cash
generation that's not investing but you
know yeah to define the words yeah they
don't experience any of it because
they're making their money from the tick
tocks
I know him he's literally made multiple
seven figures on different businesses
like he's done different business
ventures completely different stuff and
he's made Bank on both so I know this
kid he's he's not he's not talking out
of his ass he's not full of it and like
when you take those skills and like you
know your brain that you were focusing
on business and then you put it into
your personal brand that's why you're
seeing our faces everywhere because that
Focus that was on making money and was
successful is now on getting me to see
it's getting you to see my face and it's
working and all of the money that you
have made you have literally generated
out of thin air so to speak the the
business ideas you didn't have to go buy
a building you didn't have to buy
equipment you didn't have to buy
inventory this is all stuff that you did
online but you generated viable business
model and created viable businesses and
that's what these guys are saying that
anybody can do that and yes you may have
to keep your your nine to five or your
whatever job while you get started
because you have to pay the bills and
you have to eat while you're ramping up
but you did you did all of this without
any Financial investment I just I just
made a tweet where I said um if you
didn't make six figures in the last Bull
Run you need to stare in the mirror and
I'm not even lying like if if you didn't
make good money in the last Bull Run you
you need to figure something out and you
need to be ready for the next
opportunity because you could have been
in any aspect of web 3 or just like
crypto in general or even that whole
Space you could have been anywhere
involved in it and made bank I literally
ran a tick tock and I was making Bank
off of promotions and brand deals if you
did if you did drop servicing where you
offered services like um it's like
verifications if you did on you know
articles you helped people like with
marketing if you did anything there was
money to be made that's kind of my point
yeah like literally anything but you
just you didn't do anything drive you
just didn't drive in tenacity and doing
that next thing that they've made fun of
us no but I'm just saying like you could
have done any like if you were just
aware that there was money to be made
you would have made money everyone was
making money in the space I'm telling
you it was ridiculous you know there's
always one of those kids who are just
extremely good at school and they always
get straight A's [__] them yeah
I struggled so much they do different
things than me they're not focused on
wealth [__] those kids wait I want to
see if he I want to see what he says and
then say oh my God
98 of my math test and back then I used
to look at them and think holy [__]
these guys are super smart they're gonna
be really successful and now I look at
them like they're [__] trash like
[__] trash dude he's so angry that's
so obnoxious yo he's not wrong about
that when there was the kids that would
get like 95s and complain oh my God no
he's right about I wanted to serve them
a knuckle sandwich logging out but
they're not trash Oh God he's bringing
it up to [__] how I look at them and
I see how successful they are but it's
still [__] garbage and I just start
shaking I'm so unhappy
I'm so rich and I'm so angry all the
time sits in the darkness garbage
garbage garbage I Hate Everything I see
online who doesn't know jack [__] about
business then I get back the same test
and I got a 30 on it dude
I mean twenty thousand dollars scamming
kids last night and they got an A on
their test [__] them I'm a [__] alpha
male Beast one of the things that I've
learned a lot about in the past couple
years is discipline get control of your
head control your mind and learn
discipline and so you stop talking
yourself out of things and so you know
Tom Shea the Navy SEAL who we work with
I went through his 21 day challenge
where he gave me some tasks to do every
day and part of the challenge was to
wake up every day commit to doing it and
every time I started to talk myself out
of it I would have an excuse run through
my head some lame ass excuse and there
are four main excuses that he teaches
people that are that ruin lives that's
why we're doing the 21 Day Challenge
again together which Sunny is not
excited about because he's going to have
Tom on his ass if you guys actually
would like to do that with us go to the
link in the description because there's
a discount code come and do it because
guaranteed in one area of your life
there's something you're not doing
because you talk yourself out of it
every day you can go to the top of the
description click the link and buy it
with code 50 for a nice discount and
we'll be doing it with you guys we'll be
in the zoom calls and everything it'll
be cool the last night
last night thousand dollars that's your
[__]
your [__] the are you serious yeah
come on twenty thousand dollars a salary
that's below livable I think yeah
anywhere anywhere in America
dumb [__] idiot The Matrix is trying
to silence me they don't like that I'm
taking people out of the Rat Race they
don't like that I'm teaching literal 15
year olds how to make over 20 literal
15. that's how you talk about 15 year
olds when something sketchy is going on
I'm teaching literal 15 year olds they
don't like that I'm breaking the law
they don't like that I'm really into
what I do they don't like I break FTC
guidelines they don't like it I want to
help the youth really really badly he's
like the Joker of alpha males dude
Demetrius wants you to go to school
and then put you into millions of
dollars a day I mean I can't lie the
videos are like extremely cringy but
they do very well yeah I mean who's his
audience is it 15 year olds probably
yeah because he's got the crazy hair I
mean think about it like this this [__]
going on in the bottom part of the
screen the crazy hair probably who what
who had the crazy hair was it the was it
the villain in The Incredibles
I don't know it looks like him seeing a
rich person pull up in the lambo and
said I got this from going to school 100
uh yeah I am a medical doctor I've been
you know in and out school for like to
12 years
I'm you know focusing neurosurgery and I
think we all know that the doctors make
Bank like this is nothing new like I
think this whole point about college is
the people that aren't going to be
doctors and know and like if you're
going to be a doctor you know that you
get this degree you're going to get a
fat salary but a lot of these business
people that go and they just get
business degrees and all this other
[__] that doesn't have anything
studies it doesn't have anything to do
with it literature I'm just adding to
what you're saying no I know but it's
like they always bring up the same
points about doctors and lawyers and
it's like that land on my side I worked
really hard for yeah it was it was a lot
of school yep oh what's that broke
oh broke I never heard that term in my
life yeah no yeah
so I remember this time some broken came
up to me and asked me
ask me for dollars and I looked at him
and
him and I was the same premise this is
the exact same all I can see is The
Incredibles yeah another broke you came
up to it who's coming up who is coming
up to you on the street yeah it doesn't
look like particularly successful or
anything like off a glad slave like
that's just a kid 100 now or I will
teach you how to make a hundred thousand
though
oh my God each time it gets more and
more lethal
that's funny you know because in that
story I would do the same thing if I see
this kid in the street and he says you
want a hundred dollars or I'll teach you
how to make a hundred thousand I'm
saying a hundred dollars
that guy was probably like yeah you'll
know what you're talking about I'll take
100 please yeah 100 sounds nice you got
the bill I'll take it yeah like you and
I say to him all right I'll teach you
everything I know now two weeks later
the kid comes back to me and shows me a
Shopify dashboard without 200 000 on
whoa and and uh you know the sale
um uh [__] the expenses was 190 000 so
yeah so you know tough margin actually
he was pretty good return though pretty
good return this kid was 15 years old a
literal 15 year old he has a literal I
was on a one-on-one Discord call with a
literal 15 year old
that's Riley he's definitely the most
Shameless and he knows exactly again
what he's doing you're barely surviving
number one priority most important thing
hey man I wish I could hear your advice
over the [__] song thing for you to
do I'll just figure out a way to start
earning more money so that you're not
living
use it going through the Savings in case
he's not even saying like make more
money he's saying figure out how to make
more money figure it out dude what do
you want me to do you tell me I'm I I'm
buying your course I got a 200k
Lamborghini you should have I'm in debt
I spent all my money on this Lamborghini
because of you and now I have no money
figure it out my bad Seth stop being
depressed you piece of [__] I promise
you if you turned off your phone and you
are not allowed to go on any Instagram
to talk or any shows or anything and all
you're allowed to do is just go do
research on money what it is and how to
make it I guarantee you that with one
day you'll have more information and
you'll be smarter than 90. so again yeah
research on money
bro these guys are so beta oh my God the
sword like now the soy boys are starting
to get to me because I say this too and
it's so fast if you literally sit down
for one day and you're just gonna watch
videos on on entrepreneurship how to
make money and then as you watch videos
you write stuff down that you don't know
and then the next video you watch is
that thing you don't know and then it
takes you down the rabbit hole I've
talked about this yeah and it's called
research and studying that's what that's
that's when learning yeah learning it's
that simple these guys are gonna [__] on
somebody for suggesting that somebody
take the time to learn how to improve
their life that's like literally the
best advice you could have gone and like
that's literally what I did to become
successful I started with like Jordan
Welch Bia has a like entrepreneur
YouTube videos they were talking about
Drop Shipping so it's like all right I'm
gonna start a Drop Shipping Store and
then I was like all right I'm a Brokey
so rather than paying for ads I'm gonna
blow up a tick tock account and then use
that to promote my store so what I did
is I started my Tick Tock account and to
blow it up stocks are trending the time
so I started posting about stocks and
[__] and then the account blew up and
then I got brand offers and so rather
than you know transitioning that account
into promoting e-commerce I just ran
with my personal brand yeah but that
would have never started if I didn't
just start going down the rabbit hole
and trying something researching God is
very giving if you show him the true
beauty of his creation and you actually
like apply effort then he'll just reward
you with [__] that's not how it works
but yeah you know what I'm saying no
like if you don't take any steps money's
not just gonna fall in your lap right if
I get married in three years I will
cheat undoubtedly not even a question
and you know people look at that and
they'd be like oh that's crazy how could
you cheat and this then it's like okay
well if you try being in your 20s making
each Fitness plus a year you know
probably by the time I'm 30 I'll have
you know I'll have 100 million dollars
in the bank 15 million dollars I could
do now and you try having that so having
all that money that power and having all
that Temptation around for me I Know
Myself and I would personally feel like
I've missed don't get married then
dumbass you didn't have to say did have
to tell anybody this you're just making
yourself look like a bad person yeah I
mean it was just a clip of a podcast I'm
sure someone said would you get married
and then he was like well if I got
married right now I know I'd cheat so
I'm not gonna get married yeah it's just
conversation yeah guys get really bad
I'm good but undoubtedly I'm gonna
undoubtedly cheat what a [__] jerk
it's funny because it's like supposed to
be like an advice podcast says or
whatever and he's like yeah like you're
like this Rich powerful successful just
be a bad person actually yeah what
you're holding up on right now yeah just
[__] I'm gonna cave knowing myself
I'm gonna cave into bad temptations all
right now here is the this is the least
likely version you know what's funny
about that though is that These Guys
these you know these two are actually
actually make a good point you know that
he really does seem like a does make him
seem like a kind of a snake like if you
would look a woman in the eye and marry
her and then cheat on her it does tell
me a lot about your honor and your
ability to keep your word and also about
your ability to have discipline in your
life that if you can't be disciplined
enough to not uh to to resent to not
resist basic Temptations what kind of a
person are you really you've seen some
of these girls mom you've seen my DMs
lately I've been showing you my DMs man
bro
[Music]
he said he slaps the [__] out of himself
am I doing I hurt myself
slap yourself and go get the million
dollars
he's right he's a million dollars into
the bank
all that [__] buy my Discord come on
let's go join my Discord do I not look
like a millionaire
that could be like the most impassioned
one of these videos I've ever seen in
mind yeah he gets into it well it's
funny because before I make fun of them
because they're not getting into it
enough like you gotta [__] delete
Snapchat you gotta like like [__] you're
a [__] [__] like this guy's like
you're a [__] [__] yeah he's like
dude I'm not kidding this delete that
[__] all right all right I'll start
screaming bro hey no no no we don't need
another screen screaming lunatic in the
house
it's funny because like I literally only
made like five of those videos where I
sat down and just like talked to the
camera like that yeah and they just like
included all of them like they didn't
even go that Viral I haven't even seen
all of those yeah I'm sure I'm surprised
you probably saw those off for the first
time it's mostly just like our content
that's everywhere so funny is these are
probably Andrew fans absolutely and
that's why these people can be
universally made fun of dude this is
awesome this is
damn dude dude wrap that up
what up dude this is incredible pleasure
doing business I think these guys should
listen to more thank you for watching
follow me on Instagram and I'll see you
later
[Music]